we can start to work together we are a
great country in the selfish country and
a compassionate country and I intend to
make that my basis for running then over
the period
fifty years ago this week
Robert F Kennedy was assassinated
moments after winning the California
Democratic presidential primary
following his funeral here in New York
Kennedy's body was carried by train to
Washington DC along the way thousands of
mourners lined the tracks to pay their
final respects that train trip is
enshrined in the memories of those who
witnessed it and it is the subject of a
special photo exhibit on display here in
New York it was the train that stopped
the world for a moment of remembrance
the heartbroken and grief-stricken line
225 miles of train tracks for a final
farewell riding along in the train
carrying the body of Robert F Kennedy
was photojournalist Paul whew schoo
whose pictures of the eight-hour journey
are now on display at the Danziger
gallery in New York City this photograph
shows two of the constituents of Bobby
Kennedy's supporters the respect in this
in this picture that everyone is paying
to this funeral train really just chokes
you up
James Danziger the owner of the gallery
has known few scope for almost 20 years
there were other photographers on the
train and nobody did what Paul did he
had three cameras he was changing film
as he needed to and he just stuck with
this and achieved this remarkable body
of work the pictures were supposed to
appear in Look magazine but because of
its publication schedule by the time the
next issue went to print the photos were
deemed out-of-date and never published
so they were buried in the look archive
and when look folded they were donated
to the Library of Congress they weren't
catalogued and nobody knew where they
were and in 1998 a researcher at Magnum
contacted John Kennedy jr. who at the
time was publishing a magazine called
George magazine and they published a
selection of these pictures and that's
how these pictures first came out into
the world and the world took notice what
is significant about these pictures is
both on one hand photographically that
they are beautiful and moving and
incredibly well composed pictures and
then also they are a portrait of America
in all its richness and diversity come
on in CBS this morning co-anchor John
Dickerson toured the train coach that
carried RF Kay's body this is the poller
and this is where the casket was placed
Bennett Levin was one of the thousands
of bystanders in Philadelphia who came
to pay their respects fifty years ago he
now owns the coach
I think people came out because
in their hearts they believe the message
that he was offering them and that was
the only way they could show respect a
solemn feeling that can still be felt
today through few SCO's work one of the
reasons that I think the photographs are
so powerful today is that what they
stand for and what Bobby Kennedy stood
for our values that we seem to really
miss it's not just history but also a
little mystery
James Danziger tells us no one in this
picture of a family lined up according
to height has ever been identified he
says it is the most famous picture in
the collection and Bobby Kennedy was so
inspirational to so many people as you
can see through those images he used to
say he was paraphrasing agent greets
that he thought of us as the opportunity
to sort of tame the savageness of man
and make gentle the life of this world
and that's what brought people out his
fight continues to this day actually the
portrait of America a great way of
looking at it as well